[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american science
fiction comedy film called what planet
are you from
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins on a planet far away
from earth that holds only male
population they are a thousand times
more advanced in technology and are
highly evolved the people of the planet
reproduce by cloning because of this
their reproductive organs have shrunk
and disappeared no wonder they're so
productive the lack of females has
caused men to evolve into emotionless
creatures with each succeeding
generation the inhabitants of the planet
are growing more ambitious to rule the
entire universe currently they are
planning to take over the earth the
ruler of the planet graydon plans to
breed a human alien hybrid to use them
for his own good
for this they train their finest men to
go to the earth woo a lady and
impregnate her in the training they are
taught how to flirt and have sexual
intercourse the leader stresses them to
complement a woman's scent and her shoes
which is sure to land them a date after
days of training they choose the best
flirt of their kind
h14496 for the mission to earth he is
going to be known as harold anderson the
leader asks harold to be careful because
no matter the training a name like
herald is going to make this difficult
also the people on earth are
unpredictable before he sets off for
earth they attach him with an artificial
appendage that will help him have sexual
intercourse on earth an airplane is in
the air flying to phoenix arizona all of
a sudden the pilots notice something
flying towards them at great speed
moments later the mysterious force
crashes into the plane and makes it move
aggressively the said forces were harold
and gradin who have now entered the
plane through its toilet they make fun
of earth's backward technology and
revise everything about the mission one
last time graydon wishes harold luck and
flushes himself off the plane following
that harold gets out and immediately
starts to flirt with the air hostess
most of the passengers are shaken by the
turbulence they just faced so the woman
thinks it is weird that the man is
hitting on her wow harold is more like
human men than he knows she angrily asks
him to take a seat harold sits beside a
crying woman who is clearly traumatized
by the incident he compliments her shoes
and her smell but he gets no positive
response he realizes that the mission is
not going to be easy but he is
determined to get someone impregnated
after the plane has landed an employee
of the faa roland jones is called to
inspect the cause of the heavy
turbulence he has been working in the
faa for years and believes that all
undefined activities that happen on the
plane are either caused by a flock of
birds or by a drunk crew he is then
handed a video that a passenger took
when they hit turbulence somewhere else
harold gets off the plane and starts to
hit on every woman he sees when a woman
bends over his crotch starts to make a
whirring noise he figures that the
artificial organ has a defect that
whenever he is turned on it starts to
make noise the woman runs away after
hearing the vibration coming from his
pants following that herald goes to the
bank he is supposed to work at he has
already been hired because of graydon's
influence a co-worker perry gordon
befriends him and teaches him the ins
and outs of the bank he also introduces
harold to the office manager and his
girlfriend rita then harold meets his
boss who claims he is also seeing rita
somewhere else roland watches the video
from the airplane and for the first time
in his life he cannot explain what
caused the turbulence the challenge
excites him and he makes it his mission
to solve the mystery after work perry
brings harold to a strip club to get him
a girl they meet a sex worker cheryl who
agrees to spend the night with him
harold is beyond excited but cheryl is
weirded out by the loud whirring sound
coming from his crotch moreover she asks
him to wear a contraceptive which
defeats his entire purpose the next
morning he briefs perry about the
disastrous night perry promises to take
him to an aaa meeting which he claims is
an even better place to pick up girls
that night they visit one and listen to
stories about women's struggle with
alcoholism and sobriety one woman named
susan hurt catches herald's attention
after her speech he approaches her but
is stopped by the air host as he met on
the flight she asks him to spend the
night with her outside perry
accidentally bumps his car into susan's
car and the two get into an argument
somewhere else harold and the air
hostess are in bed together everything
goes well until she gets a call from a
married pilot who she loves harold
comments that she is helping him cheat
which makes her kick him out roland's
wife thinks that he is cheating on her
because he has never been this excited
to go to work he tries to explain that
he is excited about the incident that
took place at work but she doesn't
believe him at work perry's wife helen
comes to meet him harold is instantly
attracted to her but is disappointed
when he finds out she is married moments
later he notices susan talking to the
receptionist she has come to meet perry
to talk about the damages he caused the
previous day harold introduces himself
and asks her out immediately susan finds
out that he was just at the aaa meeting
to look for girls and refuses to go out
with him however a persistent herald
convinces her to go on a date they go to
a restaurant for dinner at night harold
doesn't tell her much about himself and
listens carefully when she speaks not
knowing that he has been trained to do
this susan is impressed he also claims
that his purpose in life is to have a
child which makes her believe he is not
like a typical man after dinner they go
back to her apartment harold hopes to
get lucky tonight but his plans are in
vain when susan reveals that she is
saving herself for marriage he panics
and runs to the washroom to call graydon
the leader advises him to do whatever is
necessary to impregnate her even if it
means marriage somewhere else roland
interviews the cabin crew to try to
solve the mystery the air hostess tells
him that all the passengers were
panicking except for harold who seemed
rather calm when he checks the
passengers list he discovers no one of
that name was aboard the flight the air
hostess reveals that she went on a date
with harold and also tells him about the
strange humming noise that his crotch
made when they were together the man now
has all the reasons to believe that the
unexplained turbulence was because of
herald and his vibrating crotch susan
comes to visit harold while he is at
work she hopes to go out for lunch to
make up for the disastrous date harold
brings up the topic of marriage and asks
her if she has thought about marrying
him since last night susan thinks he is
joking so to make her believe him he
gets on his knees and proposes to her
even though she is taken aback she
doesn't decline his offer right away
instead she asks for some time to think
about it later that day she meets her
friends to ask for their advice all of
them warn her against marriage but susan
has already made up her mind she claims
that she is running out of time and
cannot miss the golden opportunity she
calls harold and agrees to marry him a
few days later harold does a week's
worth of his paperwork and hands it to
perry following that he takes a leave
for the wedding on his wedding day susan
recites a paragraph long vow but he only
says that he is very happy to marry her
they are announced husband and wife and
sent on a honeymoon harold has sexual
intercourse for the first time and is
overjoyed back in the bank perry submits
harold's paperwork as his own he also
talks badly about him to his boss in
order to get a promotion when harold
gets back to work roland visits him he
inquires about the flight ticket of the
plane he boarded to get to arizona but
harold claims he has thrown it away to
find out if the air hostess was telling
the truth roland deliberately drops a
playboy magazine on the desk harold's
crotch makes a humming noise but he
manages to hide it with a pencil
sharpener when he returns home that day
he hardly acknowledges his wife and her
friends in the living room and walks to
the bedroom susan is upset about his
rude behavior but is sympathetic when he
says he had a bad day at work he is also
worried because susan hasn't gotten
pregnant yet she assumes that because of
her history of alcoholism she cannot
have a child it doesn't mean much to her
because she can still adopt a kid but
harold hopes that that is not true he
then boards another flight to talk to
graydon the man says that no matter what
he has to impregnate someone if susan
cannot get pregnant he will most
definitely have to cheat on her
somewhere else roland gets a call
reporting him of a similar jolt that a
plane faced when he finds harold on the
passenger list he starts to believe that
the man is not human
that evening he follows harold to the
bar to keep an eye on him harold meets
perry's wife helen who seduces him the
two return to her house but harold's
appendage starts to malfunction midway
he runs to the bathroom and tries to
restart it roland is outside the window
watching him he takes a picture and runs
away following that harold feels guilty
for cheating on his wife and returns
home he is met with a pleasant surprise
when susan tells him she is pregnant the
couple is overjoyed at the news
meanwhile roland's wife finds harold's
naked pictures in his drawer and assumes
that her husband is gay no matter how
much he tries to explain that he is
tracking down an alien she doesn't buy
his story that is a very strange
euphemism roland in the meantime harold
and susan go to the doctors and find out
that their baby is growing at an
exponential rate although susan has been
pregnant for only four weeks the fetus
is four months old when harold comes to
work the next day he finds out that
perry has gotten the promotion because
of the paperwork perry mocks him and
accuses him of sleeping with helen which
causes a huge argument between them the
fight ends when harold punches him in
the face at home he tells susan about
the incident and cries for the first
time meanwhile roland tells his
superiors about his theory they don't
believe him fully but permit him to
investigate the situation further after
only three months of pregnancy susan
goes into labor harold drives her to the
hospital and she gives birth to a
healthy baby boy the smile on harold's
face turns into a frown when he sees
graydon outside the room a while later
he tells susan that he will have to
leave now susan doesn't ask him a lot of
questions out of surprise she blames
herself for believing him and cries as
he leaves he boards another flight to
return to his planet roland also follows
him to see what he exactly does to make
the entire airplane move harold walks
into the washroom but before roland can
get to him the plane experiences
turbulence to roland's surprise harold
disappears from the airplane he reports
the incident to his superiors who don't
believe him and fire him from his job
back on harold's planet he tells his
fellows that they should aim for
universal peace instead of universal
domination because of this he is
arrested he also finds out that his baby
has been kidnapped and brought to the
planet an agitated herald takes his baby
and runs away to earth he appears before
susan who quickly grabs the infant she
is furious at him for everything he has
done harold proves to her that he is an
alien by flashing a bright light out of
his nose he says that he was forced to
leave her but she doesn't forgive him
when he goes outside roland catches him
however the man has already been fired
so he doesn't care about harold's secret
as they talk graydon appears and points
a gun at them but roland shoots him dead
moments later susan runs outside and
says that she loves him the two
reconcile and share a passionate kiss in
the following scene the couple is
renewing their vows in a tower after the
ceremony harold tells her that he has
been selected as the new leader of their
planet he plans to commute to stay
closer to his family subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching